c'est l'histoire d'une rencontre
improbable
d'un côté un père de famille et ses
enfants de l'autre un voyageur et son
chien de lui ils ne savent presque rien
bonjour olivier labbé de salaire le
fameux chien ils se voient pour la
première fois ouah ça lui a passé ça a
été la dernière mieux au froid très gelé
ouais hier encore david dormaient dans
la rue ben
aujourd'hui il vient s'installer chez
olivier sa famille
une famille qui a décidé d'héberger chez
elle ce sans abri pour qu'ils ne passent
pas l'hiver dehors
moi je te connais pas tu ne connais pas
aux affaires connaissance on un point
pour l'instant m voilà cours ben je me
dis que moi ça pourrait peut-être
m'arrivait et trouver quelqu'un qui tend
la main
la plate une bonne chose car ça me fait
bizarre c'est un peu drôle
mais il faut juste le temps d'une
adaptation et m'habituer mais je me dis
tu ne serais pas là
c'est encore dans la rue logé un sdf à
la maison voici la main que tend de plus
en plus de français
comment se sont-ils rencontrés et à
l'ail et en bout pourquoi les familles
vont-elles leurs portes
obligé bon grâce à cette aide et les sdf
ont-ils une chance de se réinsérer
nous avons suivi trois familles trois
histoires dans traite de citoyens avec
les plus démunis
comment accorder sa confiance du jour au
lendemain un homme qui vit dans la rue
depuis 14 ans les premiers mots de mari
et la femme d'olivier une question
jamais que marié rien non j'étais déjà
avec des copines message avait duré qu
et par rapport à quand un métier en
rapport
visiblement davie n'a pas très envie de
se livrer mais la famille fait tout pour
le mettre à l'aise
tiens je te faire voir un peu comment
comment la maison la salle de bains
douches italiennes
- kl à la chaume à wendy d'emblée la
famille reçoit cet inconnu comme un ami
wasyl me dit tu veux manger quelque
chose qu'on gèle il est plein et
placards en basset plein élan free
mouture soit on ouvre les pores soit en
louve pas quoi ça peut pas être des
demi-mesures mois voilà ça vous touche
sa ville c'est un soulagement et
et une peur aussi en même temps mais ça
c'est normal mais le petit à petit c'est
parce que c'est juste le temps de la
transition quoi mais sinon oui c'est
drôlement mieux que la rubrique est ce
que vous ressentez l'armement de passer
à table
c'est émouvant c'est émouvant je sais
fin mai
ça va changer des pâtes à emporter des
kebabs dans l'âme marie et
manutentionnaires et olivier chauffeur
routier
ils ont des revenus modestes à leur
table david est un invité à qui l'on a
réservé un repas du dimanche
coquilles saint-jacques endives au
gratin un menu qui ne lui convient pas
parce que j'aime pas les choux les
indices l'ageroute
ça tombe mal mais apparemment c'est
moins amère donc je vais goûter
mais il en faut plus pour décourager la
petite famille pour faire plaisir à
david loïc le fils aîné retourne aux
fourneaux cuisine et des surgelés mieux
la ville propre et a mon avis oui tu
peux savais faire
on dit dans la rue je crois que nous on
habite à la campagne les maisons et
trois quarts du thon elles sont grandes
et il ya toujours une chambre ou de nuit
quoi parce que des gens qui arrivent en
retraite qui ont pu comprendre la maison
nom qui pourrait faire ça
accueillir des gens est multiplié par le
nombre de devis à 65 millions
d'habitants en france et on pourrait
régler ce problème quoi puisque
maintenant si on attend donc les talent
face à ce range avec le problème c'est
que depuis longtemps les gens ils ont
compris tout ce monde tout ce qu'on se
dira nous ils ont tous rempli mais ils
ont peur de le faire ou alors il en
dolphin la première image de david la
famille la découverte sur internet
c'est un artiste de rue mulot tours de
magie c'est comme cela qu'ils se sont
rencontrés
c'est cette vidéo qui les a convaincus
on y voit david faire des tours de magie
leur premier contact a eu lieu il ya un
mois grâce à un nouveau réseau
d'entr'aide le 115 du particulier créée
par un ancien sdf
ce site met en relation d'un côté des
familles qui propose un hébergement de
l'autre des personnes qui cherchent un
toit
je suis là pour offrir un hébergement
provisoire
je recherche un hébergement pour pouvoir
m'en sortir et trouver un travail
marie et olivier y ont déposé une
annonce et laisser leurs coordonnées
david les a contactés ils vont parler au
téléphone plusieurs fois avant de
l'inviter chez eux
sinon on m'a dit oui tout de suite c'est
parce que au niveau du téléphone déjà ça
passait puis skype yahoo way à ça et
puis je sais pas le faire moi je sais
pas j'ai une certaine intuition sa part
ça passe ça va se passa passe pas le ton
est déterminé tout autant que cette mise
en garde
belle façon moi je suis frau quoi ouais
on est très franc c'est à dire que si ça
va pas laraque
non si ça va ça va quoi il ya des
moments où je crois peut-être blues
bourdon parce qu'il ya le passé qui
rattrape un peu et il faut que faut que
je fasse un peu le
là dedans mais mais mais c'est des
choses qui vont pas durer quoi je veux
dire la détresse de david a aussi émue
marie peut-être pas par hasard s'il est
franchement mon amour passé moi je suis
divorcée depuis 2008
je partage ma vie depuis 20 ans avec la
lhjmq se rappelle en permanence qu'il a
baissé en permanence
voilà donc je me suis barré que mes gars
1 j'aurais pu voir trop le scala dans
ton cas basser ce qui s'est passé au
début avec ma mère mon père violent
flics et puis moi quand je rentrais
c'était toujours ma mère sur le
carrelage à présent les enfants de marie
sont grands et ils n'habitent plus avec
elle loïc et wendy sont les enfants
d'olivier une famille recomposée
habitué aux cohabitation compliquée
comme ils n'ont pas assez de chambres
c'est au milieu de leurs salons qu'ils
ont décidé d'installer david ne reste
plus qu'à aller chercher un matelas dans
le garage après tu vois là et me remette
dehors avec un matelas c'est ça que j'ai
gagné
un lit après des années de bitume un
faux-cul valls
radiateur occasions ratées ou
confortable je vois le bout des doigts
moi je pense que ça ira mieux quand je
tombe bien david n'est là que depuis
quelques heures et il a déjà gagné la
confiance de la famille les parents lui
ont demandé d'aider wendy dix ans à
faire ses devoirs
visiblement entre le sdf et la petite
le courant passe blanc ici il faut
mettre le
vous imaginez les crises comme ça c'est
bien
c'est un proche la mère de sentir menacé
c'est ce que je recherchais cours
david n'a jamais eu d'emploi stable il a
quitté l'école à l'âge de 16 ans et a
suivi une formation dans une école de
cirque
il lui tendre la main
mais en retour ils sont des attentes
qu'il anime la maison qu'ils
s'impliquent des demandes qu'ils n'ont
pas formulé clairement
après 14 ans dans la rue le soir venu
pour david la vie d'avant semble ne pas
s'effacer si elle les habitudes de la
rue qui subsiste un peu avant d'aller se
coucher
voilà deux d'enlever zavvi préféré
partir directement relié avec les
habitent ce que j'ai l'habitude en irak
les haricots
je dors pas songé à me j même les
environs mais bon ça va paraître bizarre
ce que je vais dire mais ça fait du bien
de dieu c'est cool ben pas un lit un
matelas et c'est un truc bizarre qui va
arriver c'est que en fait c'est avec la
rue me manque mais les habitudes de rêve
me manque c'est tellement d habitude qui
me permet d'être à l'aise que là je me
sens mieux pour dormir mais chut
paraissent de plus en plus de familles
hébergent chez elle des sans abri mais
la démarche n'est pas sans ambiguïté ni
sans abus la générosité de certains
n'est pas toujours désintéressés
notre enquête nous emmène près du havre
chez sylvie et paulo deux ouvriers à la
retraite ils ont déjà logé plusieurs
sans abri
six personnes en un an
comment ça se passe la cohabitation avec
des personnes comme ça et bah c'est pas
toujours évident mais bon pour mon
univers du cirque c'est tout mais la
main à la poche c'est sévère mais sinon
autrement ça va françois 51 ans est
arrivé ici il y a trois jours dans
l'urgence il vient d'être expulsé de son
logement
il a contacté paulo sur le site u115 du
particulier bon ça serait pas monté
rapidement
ça c'est pour le suis par manquer ses
polos et sylvie l'accueil est rustique
il ne s'en cache pas en échange du toit
il ya une contrepartie c'est quoi les
règles un petit peu qu'il doit y avoir
des règles pour que ça se passe bien
langues diraient élémentaire c'est tout
le monde la propre travail
françois on ne peut comprendre ça pour
une agression comme une preuve que mons
tout mon travail c'est des trucs de la
vieille école ou participer c'est tout à
fait réglé par une colonie de vacances
ici logique ou pas tout à fait à l'aise
bon se plier aux règles aux principes de
cette famille qui l'accueille sans avoir
son mot à dire
lui qui a tout perdu depuis deux ans
donc ça c'est moi quand tu vois quand
j'étais dans mon activité
professionnelle
j'avais une vie leur une famille ma
fille formidable travail ce qui lui
plaisait en tant que gérant de société
donc la vie la vie se passait très bien
mes filles ça s'est super bien passé et
puis du jour au lendemain mais le flash
froid lundi force du sila subir et puis
à quoi c'est très blessant dix ans on
avait une vie normale partie de la
société normale et puis du genre main on
se trouvait script partout quand t'as
pas toutes les portes se ferment un
exclu sur lequel le regard des autres a
changé quand paulo s'adresse à lui
c'est pour lui demander d' entretenir le
jardin d'engager des travaux dans la
maison
la tâche de françois ce matin là c'est
de dégager ce débarras qui lui sert de
chambre
en fait vous allez pouvoir faire un
petit chez vous ici
à bâle ça va être nickel manger par
terre
accepter de se retrousser les manches
pour dormir au chaud
lui l'ancien gérant doit désormais
accepté les ordres d'un autre il lui
faut ranger des années de vieilleries
accumulés par le couple et polo ne le
quitte pas des yeux
alors qu il se fait son petit nid chez
vous une des réflexions à caractère
raciste que françois ne comprends pas
mais quand il lui demande de répéter
pour lui préfère passer à autre chose
à l'évidence ce qu'attend paulo c'est
tout simplement que françois remettre
toute sa maison en ordre
et puis j'ai celle là qu'on n'entend
jamais ménagé d'une ferme des parents
aussi
cela vous soyez prêt à accueillir encore
quelqu'un là
mais bon ya pas ou dans la mesure du
possible un toit en échange d'un travail
une hospitalité plus qu'ambiguë nous
retrouverons françois dans quelques
jours à châtillon-sur-indre chez marie
et olivier david prend ses marques
quel statut pour l'ancien sdf dans la
maison invités amis il est aussi devenu
la nounou de la famille tous les matins
il réveille la petite wendy lui prépare
son petit déjeuner pendant que marie est
au travail
olivier lui cherche des missions de
routiers sur internet
la place accordée à cet inconnu
n'est-elle pas trop grande
il ya des gens qui doivent se dire ouais
quand même accueillir quelqu'un comme ça
chez toi chez soi on connaît pas mais en
réfléchissant bien une maman célibataire
qui rencontrent quelqu'un pour qui elle
un coup de foudre
elle va l'accueillir chez elle le
connaît pas plus david s'occupe de wendy
et olivier accompli les tâches ménagères
les deux hommes donnent l'impression
d'avoir presque inverser les rôles
wendy tu proposes catégorie peuple est
séduit aussi qui l'accompagnent à
l'école je peux être loin de sa vie du
sdf
david découvre la vie de famille se
lever tôt le matin respecter les
horaires donner un coup de main des
règles qui n'ont pas été annoncé mais
qu'ils respectent depuis son arrivée
indoor
ce soir en var
c'est agréable pour vous vous aimez
faire ça ouais ça me some change un peu
mon quotidien et puis et puis ça me fait
rappeler des choses que j'avais plus
ignares et très longtemps voilà rentré
prendre un
dans cette relation entre david et
olivier les préjugés sont parfois mises
à mal ce matin c'est le sdf qui instruit
le père de famille
l'âme est donc la journée à la maison je
n'arrive pas à faire tourner le truc
c'est dans la rue il sait c'est internet
mieux que moi tu passes et ajournant
dans les cybercafés
ou sur l'ordinateur je regrette pas être
vraiment je regrette pas du tout parce
que mon par rapport à ce qu'il n'a pas à
ce qu'ils endurent et
et c'est adapté mais c'est comme si
c'était quelqu'un de la famille qui
vient cours en fait un
une semaine de cohabitation seulement et
olivier veut déjà offert son associé
dans un projet qui lui tient à coeur
devenir gérant de camping
ce matin ils emmènent david sur le
terrain qu'ils envisagent d'acheter un
rêve dans lequel il tient à l'impliquer
j'ai toujours dans l'idée de le mettre
en place en plus l'avantagé avec david
c'est que au niveau informatique il est
calé très calé donc moi c'est un peu le
coup ça pêcher dans mon projet
maintenant david heap participer safa
super quoi maintenant 12 y asthme et
même peu de mots david lui ne confie
rien de ces projets nous reviendrons
dans quelques jours en indre et loire
peut-on changer la vie de ceux que l'on
aide la main tendue est elle toujours
accéder à l'abri des regards une tente
au fond d'un bois près de la ville de
bourges
elle abrite deux jeunes sdf et leurs
chiens
nicolas surnommé pom pom 33 ans et sa
petite amie alexandrie à 21 ans vivent
ici depuis un an
la nuit a été dur la température a frôlé
les 0° c'est l'horreur alexandria est
enceinte de cinq mois elle pourrait
trouver une place dans un foyer
d'urgence mais elle refuse de se séparer
de son homme elle préfère supporter
cette précarité extrême grossesse à
vapeur
ça va la lui il est au chaud il dormira
y mange bien
les deux jeunes ont pris un mauvais
départ dans la vie
alexandria est orpheline elle s'est
retrouvée à la rue à 19 ans seulement
nicolas pompon lui a multiplié les
petits boulots mais n'a jamais eu de
logements durables tous les deux
touchent le rsa environ 700 euros pour
le coup pour survivre ils font là
mangeant les rues commerçantes de
bourges apparemment leur avion ne fait
pas peur aux habitants du quartier
saint-laurent
parmi eux laurent et sa fille de huit
ans quand même je me lève pour ce faire
la ville
tu vas bien ma fille me l'école à 11h30
et c'est un peu une tradition voilà les
voir nico est et alexandria ses chiens
dans la mesure où ils ont un rapport
extrêmement presque familiale faut bien
le dire depuis bien longtemps
il a déjà tenté de les sortir de la rue
mais les deux jeunes y retourne toujours
que laurent et sa famille habitent à une
centaine de mètres de là lui est
professeur de philosophie sa femme
cécile enseigne le français au lycée
le couple anime une émission de radio
qui donne la parole aux plus démunis et
dialogue avec eux c'est vrai qu'on a
souvent l'habitude de discuter avec les
gens avaient auquel des fois ça donne
une pièce ont de bons clubs
c'est vrai que on s'arrête pour discuter
bon on va pas donné de l'argent comme ça
sans s'intéresser aux gens et donc on a
commencé à discuter avec avec nicolas
corps alexandria et pompons dean une
fois par semaine chez eux ce soir ils
sont attendus surtout par la petite
saskia qui guettent leur arrivée
bonsoir
malgré une grande précarité
les deux jeunes ne viennent jamais les
mains vides un peu alors on va vous
apporter une bonne cuvée
entre les deux femmes
la complicité est forte alexandria
montre sa dernière échographie à cécile
à moi ça me rappelle et j'ai les mêmes
derrière j'ai commandé leur âge
n'attendez pas j'étais j'ai vu pour voir
était content donc alexandria aussi nous
la première réflexion après ça j'ai eu
c'est on n'a pas un gros fonds dans la
rue à un morceau fait savoir qu
alexandria dort dehors inquiète le
couple il voudrait lui offrir un toit
dans les combles ils ont une chambre
vide
le confort est sommaire mais il y fait
chaud pourtant les deux jeunes refusent
de s'y installer
j'évite au maximum demain peser chez les
gens c'est l'impression de s'imposer
surtout ma fierté c'est d'abord de
d'essayer de me démerder tout seul avant
de demander d'appeler au secours quoi
votre douche alors partir comme ça va
faire là sachant que c'est pas facile
mais bon c'est leur vie aussi veut pas
s'incruster laurent et sa femme ont
compris qu'ils ne réussiront pas les
héberger chez eux mais ils pensent à une
autre solution pour leur trouver un toit
illégale cette fois ci nous retrouvons
françois le sans abri qui résidait chez
les deux retraités du havre à plus de
350 km de l'ain à la guerre de cholet
dans le maine-et-loire
il est parti de chez ces prétendus
bienfaiteurs commencé à venir un petit
peu pénible à supporter donc lui on est
quand même des réactions très violentes
donc et surtout à il cherchait quelqu'un
un petit peu un genre d'esclaves pourra
retarder sa maison après s'il ya des
gens qui accèdent pour mieux pour
revenir mais bon c'est pas le cas pour
moi dans la nuit j'ai préparé mes
affaires et le lendemain matin j'ai
profité de l'absence de polo qui est
parti faire des courses pour hbo furent
donc
un peu la peur au ventre on soupe
archives francois préfère repartir dans
la rue plutôt que d'être hébergé chez un
autre particulier quand apollo et sylvie
nous sommes retournés les voir pour les
interroger sur leurs expériences avec
françois ils n'ont l'air ni surpris ni
culpabiliser de son départ précipité
parce qu'il a eu peur je sais pas quand
je prends quand même mais mes parties
change your world sans rien paulo nous
montre le travail qu'a fait françois il
a abattu ce mur dans la cuisine et il a
aussi commencé la rénovation de cette
chambre
pour finir le chantier polonais déjà
tout prévu
ça va être de boult aux bois
le ti gars c'est un autre sans abri qui
doit arriver le soir même
il ignore qu'il va devoir travailler
très dur pour gagner son toit paulo l'a
recrutée via le 115 du particulier le
site se contente de mettre en contact
sans contrôle à bourges
laurent a donné rendez vous sur un
parking à pompons et alexandria les deux
jeunes sdf qui dorment dans les bois
avec un élu écologiste de la ville ils
ont repéré un logement vide
parfait pour accueillir les deux jeunes
et leur bébé à venir
quand on a un jeune couple avec une
jeune femme enceinte avec cette
température là il ya des réponses à
trouver alors qu'elle soit légale ou
peut chercher il ya des institutions
mais des fois elles sont illégales et la
place d'un élu c'est aussi c'est pas
uniquement derrière un bureau ou dans
une assemblée c'est aussi aller au
charbon
laurent et l'élu accompagne le couple
pour prendre possession des lieux
un logement social en cours de
rénovation inoccupé depuis un an et demi
c'est la première fois que laurent
entreprend une action illégale
l'humanité justifie pleinement cet acte
qui pour moi relève pas du tout
de la délinquance et des actes citoyens
un acte citoyen mais laurent préfère
tout de même laissé pont pour ont forcé
la serrure
le logement est un quatre pièces en très
bon état et surprise il est habitable
immédiatement voilà s'allumeront
chercher le magot
entre 3 il y à même le chauffage dans
ces lots est là c'est en tant que futur
plein de familles pauvres santécois
d'acter site web au moins samedi que moi
c'est lundi que je galère pour trouver
quelque chose pour mettre ma femme et ma
fille à l'abri et que joua des logements
comme ça qui sont abandonnés
pratiquement très bon état et qu' ils
sont pas foutus de nous en donner un
quand on en cherche un alors que ben
voilà on va avoir un enfant n'est
considérée comme personnes prioritaires
normalement sera connue depuis notre
tournage pompons et alexandria ont
quitté leur squat la préfecture leur a
attribué un logement social en toute
légalité cette fois